PROFESSOR: So this is
our adiabatic change.
So now we can say
several things.
OK, if omega is changing slowly,
the energy is changing slowly,
but do we have something that
changes even more slowly,
something that really
almost doesn't change?
What you need here
is basically--
this was a very
important discovery
in classical mechanics.
You need like two
things that change.
Everything is going
to change slowly,
but then there's going to be
one thing that changes slowly
and another thing
that changes slowly,
and they change kind of in
the same way in such a way
that the ratio or some
combination of them
doesn't change almost at all.
That's what we're trying to get.
Anybody knows in classical
mechanics what quantity here
doesn't change much?
Nobody.
No clue?
It's not obvious what
doesn't change much,
but here is the claim.
Claim is that the quantity
that doesn't change much
is, in fact, the energy
divided by omega.
The energy will change slowly.
Omega will change slowly.
But the ratio is almost
not going to change at all.
So here is the claim.
There is an I of t called
adiabatic invariant, which
is basically H of t
divided by omega of t,
and it's almost constant.
And this quantity has the
units of energy times time.
I don't want to give
away the whole story.
But I think it's good
if you, at this moment,
think a second, well, what
could it mean, or do I even have
a clue why this could happen?
And you think oh,
quantum mechanics.
The harmonic oscillator,
what happened?
The energy was equal to
h omega times the level.
So kind of energy
divided by omega
is kind of a nice quantity.
It's a quantum number.
Quantum numbers are
quantized, and they
don't like to
change, because how
could an integer change slowly?
As soon as it changes,
it changes big.
So a little bit of
what we're getting at
is the resistance of a system
to change quantum level.
When something is quantized,
it cannot change slowly,
and the adiabatic invariant is
exploiting in classical physics
that quantum
property, if you wish.
So let's look at that.
So the claim is that the name
i is for adiabatic invariant,
and we can verify it, and get
some intuition as to why those
very slowly.
Now, I cannot prove that
thing doesn't change.
That would be too much, but it's
going to change very slowly.
You will appreciate that.
Let's see.
Let's compute the
derivative, di dt.
So it's a ratio.
So I have omega squared.
Omega.
I'm going to use
dots, and I'm going
to stop writing the
factor, the key dependents.
Omega H dot minus H omega dot.
So what do we have here?
Omega, H dot was calculated
up there, m omega,
omega dot x squared minus
H p squared over 2m minus--
no, minus.
Plus 1/2 m omega squared
x squared times omega dot
over omega squared.
And well, I still remember
when I first saw that.
I probably wanted the numerator
to cancel and to do something
very nice and simplify a lot.
But it doesn't happen.
So let's see what
really happens.
Well, you have this
term, omega squared,
omega dot, x squared
m, omega squared,
omega dot, x squared m.
But the factors of 2
don't make it cancel.
So it's there.
So let me write what we
get when we simplify this.
di dt is equal to omega dot
over omega squared times
1/2 m omega squared x squared
minus p squared over 2m.
That term is clear.
The p squared is that, and
here, we cancel the 1, partially
with a 1/2.
So we've got this.
OK, so it doesn't look
like it wants to be 0.
But it's still very good.
Let's see why that
result is nice.
Well, one thing you realize
here is that it actually
gave you kind of
back the Hamiltonian
with a different sine there.
This is negative, and
this will remain positive.
So let's write this, this
omega dot omega squared.
And this is the kinetic energy
minus the potential energy,
well, the potential
energy v of t
minus the kinetic energy k of
t in the harmonic oscillator.
Moreover, this quantity
is already very small.
So this thing is very
small, but the fact
that the adiabatic
invariant is adiabatic
that it's really good,
should go beyond this.
There should be something
suppressing about this factor,
because you know, this
came from just the fact
that things vary with omega dot.
So what is happening?
This is small and
slowly varying.
This is neither small, nor
slowly varying, in fact.
Why?
Potential minus kinetic energy.
The potential energy
in an oscillator
goes up when the
kinetic energy is 0.
I see the oscillator goes
to the end, stretches
[INAUDIBLE] potential energy is
large, the kinetic energy is 0.
As it goes through the
center, the equilibrium point,
the kinetic energy is larger.
So this is oscillating.
And it's very large,
but now, you probably
remember this fact about
the harmonic oscillators.
While the potential and
kinetic energies oscillate,
their averages are the same.
So that's how this term
is going to help you.
The average of this quantity
is roughly 0 over any period.
And a period over a period,
this quantity changes little.
So this is going to help us.
Let me remind you here, suppose
you have an oscillation,
an x equals sine omega t, then
the momentum would be m x dot,
so m omega cosine omega
t, and the kinetic energy
minus the potential energy, if
you do this little calculation,
will go like omega
squared cosine of 2
omega t, the v minus k.
I leave for you that
little calculation.
But it will go like cosine of
2 omega t, twice the period.
And that thing tends
to have a 0 average.
So let's see what happens now.
The idt to see
what happens to it.
Let's calculate I at t plus
the period minus I at some t.
So let's see how much
I changes in a period.
So from here, we
have the derivative.
So we must do the integral
from t to t plus t of the dI dt
prime dt prime.
So this will be the
integral from t to t
plus capital T of this whole
thing, omega dot over omega
squared of t times v of t--
it's all t prime, actually-- vt
prime minus kt prime dt prime.
Let's see that.
You have the
derivative of I, so you
can calculate the change in I by
integrating with the derivative
of I over mep.
We've done that, and we've
asked how much does this thing
change over a period.
Then we have that I of
t plus t minus I of t,
we have an integral
over a period.
We set this quantity very slowly
and very little over a period,
so roughly speaking, this is
equal to omega dot over omega
squared at t.
It didn't change much
over the integral.
And then we have the
integral over a period
of the potential energy
minus the kinetic energy.
And for a normal oscillator
that is time independent,
this quantity is strictly 0.
If omega was not changing,
this would be identically 0.
So if omega is changing
slowly, this quantity
must be very close to 0.
It's identically 0
when it doesn't change.
Therefore, you see you got
an extra suppression factor.
The change in the adiabatic,
so-called adiabatic invariant
over time was already small,
because everything goes slow.
But there is an
extra suppression
due to the fact that
these two energies have
the same average over a period.
So you gain something.
If the energy changes slowly,
this energy over omega
changes even much
more slowly than that.
So this is really exactly 0
for time independent omega,
approximately 0 for slow
omega, slowly changing omega.
So that's the extra
suppression factor,
and that's what makes this an
adiabatic invariant, something
that really changes
dramatically slower
in a system in which everything
is already changing slowly.